Okay, so the way my room is set up right now,
I have my bed here and the TV,
like, right across from it.
But there was a time where I put my bed against that wall,
like, that was above my bed.
And so to watch TV,
I have to go like this.
Like, if I was gonna be in my bed,
I have to be like this to watch TV.
Let me tell you how that fucked up my neck.
And let me tell you how this fucking pillow from the TikTok shop.
Oh, my god, sees my ass. Because, like,
I love you see it,
like, from the side,
it keeps your back, like,
perfectly lined correctly.
So I fucking. I feel like it helped tremendously.
And then I got the freaking mattress.
This really firm as mattress was 6 x up to
TikTok Shop has saved my life.
Just kidding. Just kidding.
That's quite an exaggeration.
But if you do want the pillow or the mattress,
they're in my showcase or linked right here,
cause it's definitely worth it.